i i just can't with this hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by built bar
and we'll be reviewing vanessa 2's guide
on how to be that girl and sharing my
overall thoughts on this controversial
tick tock trend but first let me tell
you about my sponsor build bar now i'm
not gonna lie i do try
not to plan the recording of my videos
around snack time because i get a little
i get a little extra feisty which i know
some of you actually like but i love
when it's a build bar sponsor day
because it just
brings me down on the hanger scale and
that just levels me out a little bit but
you guys know i don't love a whole lot
of different kinds of protein bars out
there
most of them taste like chalk
masquerading is a health food i'm not
for that oh no oh no but these bad boys
taste like a chocolate bar with the
added bonus of the fact that they are
packed with protein so folks let's take
a look at which one we're having today
oh there's lots of fades in here but the
mint chocolate
she's calling my name
oh my gosh
travesty dave
[Music]
good
and 17 grams of protein so you guys know
this is a lower sugar bar so i often
like to turn this into a hunger crushing
combo by pairing it with like an apple
with peanut butter or some avocado toast
just build out a more saturating bigger
snack or meal and if you want to give
these bars a try
check out my promo code abbiesharp15 for
15 off of your order and you can check
out the link in my description also you
can pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating as always please
feel free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and if you
are not already subscribed hit that sub
button ring that bell and follow me on
tik tok and instagram abby's kitchen all
right folks
let's settle in so
if your tick tock for you page looks
anything like mine then you've seen more
of your fair share of videos on how to
be that girl who that girl is or where
she came from
i do not know but basically these videos
are intended to serve as motivation to
be your healthiest most productive self
and while i fully support
self-development healthy habits and
doing the things that make you feel
great i do have a bit of a bone to pick
with the toxic messaging that this trend
can sometimes perpetuate and obviously i
want to talk about it now as always
google is reading my mind because
vanessa's guide on how to be that girl
just like popped up in my suggested
videos this week and i thought it would
be a good jumping off point to discuss
this trend so let's take a look
personally i really think that that girl
trend is about being productive it's
supposed to be really motivating it's
more so working towards the best version
of yourself being that ideal girl that
you have in your head and it looks
different for everybody and i really
think that this trend motivates people
to keep growing and like change little
things in their daily routines daily
habits that they can implement that
overall just helps to improve their life
okay so in short vanessa describes the
that girl trend as an external motivator
to help you be your best self whatever
that looks like uniquely for you now
while i agree that what works for you
might not work for someone else i do
feel like this context and nuance
often does get lost within like a 30
second tick tock instead a lot of the
videos come off as being very
prescriptive and inauthentic basically
just copy and pasted footage of all the
aesthetically pleasing ways that that
girl lives her life and how she
miraculously does it all before 9 a.m
and while this might be motivating for
some people like vanessa who can maybe
easily integrate this lifestyle into
their day-to-day life it can also feel
feelings of guilt and inadequacy in
others you know if the routines don't
align with that girl in other words my
concern is that this trend paints a
perfect ideal that just might not be
attainable for
99.99 of people who have i don't know
obligations responsibilities or even
just aspirations beyond the life they
portray online but more on that later
for now let's jump into vanessa's guide
on how to be that girl personally i feel
like the batgirl day starts with the
night routine i'm gonna get up at 5 50.
[Music]
some of the other like little habits
that i picked up for like drinking a
lemon water doing gratitude and
journaling which i do sometimes i don't
do every day going for a morning walk
you know green juice morning workouts
healthy breakfast to-do lists all that
good stuff anyone else feel overwhelmed
by this because i feel overwhelmed and i
am speaking as someone who wakes up at 5
00 a.m naturally and likes early
productive mornings but the performance
of this
feels like a lot like does everyone
stretch in their bed when their alarm
goes off because i literally either roll
out or jump out depending on how
desperate my kids screams are but
anyways if you like an early morning
wake up and also have the flexibility to
dedicate several hours to like a
comprehensive morning routine before
starting the work day then amazing
but i also want to validate those folks
who
just don't have that kind of time or
energy or money or flexibility in their
day and it doesn't mean you're not that
girl or that you're lesser than or that
you're failing or that you even need to
change anything about the way you do
things it just means that you're
honoring your needs and what's
manageable for you and while i'm a
strong believer that routines can be a
very powerful productivity tool with
research suggesting that they can
support mental health and give you a
sense of purpose but it's also worth
noting
that routines do take a lot of time to
establish with some research suggesting
that it can take anywhere from two to
four months for healthy behaviors to
become habitual it's also important to
start small to ensure it's something
that you can actually sustain or that
you want to sustain so find what feels
good to you
add something in or take something out
switch it up day to day or stick to the
same routine whatever works you don't
need to add a bunch of tasks to your
morning if the end results just leave
you feeling more overwhelmed and
stressed out because i didn't have any
lemons
so we are having warm lime water
okay
it's not
horrible
so i'm gonna do my little five minute
gratitude journal as well as my
daily to-do list so it wouldn't be a
healthy girl morning routine without a
classic lemon water feature
well when life gives you lemons
or in her case lime water but regardless
i am glad that she's starting her
morning with some hydration without the
pseudoscience lemon water claims but
lemon water aside for vanessa
being that girl isn't just about taking
care of your physical health but also
your mental and emotional well-being and
that's why she tries to focus on
gratitude and her daily to-do list in
the morning now there is research to
support a link between gratitude and
mental health as it can help to provide
a greater sense of well-being and life
satisfaction as well as being a
protective factor against feelings of
depression and anxiety research also
shows that creating a to-do list can
help to kind of de-clutter your mind
help you feel more organized and reduce
feelings of stress but again we need
these tasks to help rather than hinder
us so if you have an extra five to ten
minutes in the morning to dedicate to
these tasks in a way that is manageable
and not daunting
then amazing but if it's not something
that you find personally helpful then i
would say it's not for you
[Music]
okay next up vanessa goes for a 30
minute walk followed by an outdoor
workout which strongly aligns with the
that girl trend of getting in that
morning sweat sesh so some folks do
prefer movement in the morning myself
included as it can really help to
energize them before they start their
day and there is even research
supporting moderate intensity exercise
in the morning as a way to help boost
cognitive functions like decision making
memory and attention in other words your
morning workout does not need to be
super intense or rigorous to reap the
brain boosting benefits but i also get
that not everyone has the time or energy
to do like a one hour workout in the
morning or maybe they prefer to exercise
at the end of the day when the pressure
of the day is behind them i say a little
goes a long way and again you don't have
to do too much too fast start small and
see what works and feels manageable for
you
okay so another aspect of being that
girl is eating healthy aesthetic meals
which can be a bit problematic when
taken into disordered eating territory
but i'm gonna get further into that
later on so if i put my dietitian hat on
i of course love that we're getting lots
of carbs and fiber from the oats and the
fruit to refuel those energy stores
after her morning workout plus we're
getting some protein and fat from the
peanut butter and some more fats from
the coconut chips now if we really want
to optimize our post-workout meal for
protein muscle synthesis we could sneak
in some extra protein here maybe by
cooking this with soy milk some whipped
egg whites or some silken tofu or
topping it off with some hemp hearts and
or chia seeds
[Music]
something else that i haven't talked
about yet but i feel like i should
because i've seen this in a lot of
routines as well is reading and like
reading for enjoyment or reading for
self-improvement now the rest of
vanessa's pursuit of being that girl
involves doing some work while she eats
her breakfast followed by some grocery
shopping and reading her book before she
makes lunch again if you have the
flexibility in your day to dedicate to
personal chores and leisure activities
like reading amazing but i think i can
speak for most of us when i say that you
know if you're working a nine-to-five or
you're a full-time student or you're a
stay-at-home parent pausing for a few
hours in the middle of the work day to
do any of the above is highly
unrealistic so if you're watching this
and racking your brain as to how
you're gonna fit all of this stuff into
your day and still somehow tend to your
professional academic or parenting
obligations take this as a reminder that
you do not have to do it all focus on
what is manageable even if it doesn't
look anything
like this with that said let's take a
look at what that girl eats for lunch
and vinegar a little bit of olive oil
salt and pepper and some italian
seasoning
so i like that we're getting more
protein in this lunch meal compared to
her breakfast thanks to the tuna and the
chickpeas as well we're also getting
tons of healthy fats from the avocado
and the green olives as well as some
fiber and micronutrients from all the
veggies i also like that she's having a
green juice as like an add-on to her
meal and not as the star of the show she
also mentioned earlier in the video that
she'll usually make some kind of like a
green smoothie instead of green juice
because it's just more satiating for her
but in the interest of being that girl
she opted for the green juice instead so
i get that she made the switch for the
purpose of this video but this also
speaks to the impact of a trend like
this and how it can alter your already
quite healthy habits
just to fit into someone else's ideal
folks a green juice won't inherently
make you healthier the same way that
drinking lemon water or waking up at 5am
won't either
and if you want my expert yet totally
moot point opinion the smoothie which
she was having before becoming that girl
would have actually been a healthier
choice but unfortunately the messaging
from these videos as well as other kind
of similar wellness trends like what i
in a day videos feed us a service level
picture of what healthy should look like
and a lot of these rules are total bs
now with all that said here are four
reasons why i think the that girl trend
is problematic number one it perpetuates
toxic social media comparison you know
the saying comparison is the fifa joy
well this is actually supported by
scientific evidence research suggests
that idealistic social comparison on
social media can impact self-esteem
and prolonged use can increase feelings
of depression anxiety and stress it can
also create social pressure to create an
online image that aligns with that of
your peers in other words focusing too
much on what that girl is doing just
fuels feelings of inadequacy if you're
not being productive enough working out
enough waking up early enough eating
healthy enough etc and while some days
it may feel great to do all of these
things it can also push you beyond your
bandwidth which is the perfect recipe
for burnout what i want you to remember
here is that social media is just a
highlight reel and is not an accurate
representation of everyday life so a lot
of us aren't seeing when that girl takes
a break now reason number two is that it
presents one unified image of healthy
the that girl trend pushes a one size
fits all ideal of what living your best
healthiest life should look like and
while i appreciate the vanessa prefaces
for video by acknowledging that one
person's healthiest self can look very
different from someone else's her guide
still follows the exact same formula as
pretty much every other video i've seen
on the trend which again unfortunately
demonstrates a very narrow and
privileged definition of health i would
love to see a that girl video that feels
a little less carbon copy and a little
more authentic to that unique individual
and maybe even showcases some of the
more boring and less aesthetic ways that
someone feels like their best self
because a lot of the time feeling good
doesn't always look aesthetic or
glamorous sometimes it means coming out
of a therapy session and having a good
cry or taking a long ass nap or digging
into some comfort foods that are unique
to your culture or having a really good
embarrassing belly laugh
it's okay if working on yourself is
boring and mundane and imperfect that to
me is far more relatable and accessible
than creating an idealistic expectation
of how you should be living now reason
number three
is it may promote disordered eating one
of the main staples of this trend is
what you eat and how much you work out
and this message is almost exclusively
coming from thin women in other words it
pushes the narrative that in order to be
accepted into the that girl club you
must only eat healthy food work out
every day and have a small privileged
body the implicit goal then is no longer
about being productive and feeling your
best but instead is about looking good
by toxic social media standards and for
those with histories of disordered
eating and eating disorders this can be
highly triggering and is the same
messaging that fuels orthorexic
tendencies in fact research has shown a
strong association between frequency of
social media use and disordered eating
among young people and just given the
fact that tick tock is highly
unregulated to begin with this trend
only feeds into the diet culture
rhetoric just running rampant on your 4u
page finally reason number four
it's not realistic or accessible to most
folks what bugs me about this trend in
particular is that it creates an
unrealistic standard that your
productivity and health are only valid
if they look a certain way that you
should have multiple hours at your
disposal to make an instagram worthy
breakfast drink a liter of lemon water
go for a hot girl walk do a full pilates
workout with the cute matching set drink
your green juice write in your journal
meditate shower do your 10 steps skin
care routine and read two chapters of a
best-selling book all before
9 a.m who
has that kind of time like even on a
weekend it's a lot so balancing work and
life as that girl all day every day is
next to impossible especially for women
with family responsibilities so don't
kill yourself in pursuit of trying to do
it all because social media has told you
to i mean life is chaotic it's
unpredictable and in covetings it is
hella exhausting like some of us over
here are just trying to survive another
day
no more so maybe that girl for you looks
nothing like the girls on tick tock
maybe that girl is working on fostering
more self-love maybe that girl spends
her days dedicated to working hard and
finishing her degree so she can land her
dream job maybe that girl shows up to
therapy to heal her trauma and tend her
emotional needs maybe that girl works by
day and raises her family by night maybe
that girl sleeps until noon when her
body needs rest and doesn't feel guilty
about it maybe that girl eats balanced
meals most days but doesn't eat any
vegetables other days maybe that girl is
breastfeeding two babies at once for
most of us that girl is not the same
girl and that girl doesn't look the same
every day and most of the time
self-improvement is not aesthetic or
glamorous but the point is that girl
should be unique to you and not
something that tick-tock tells you it
should be so on that note
that is all that i have for you guys
today thank you again to buildbar for
sponsoring if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up subscribe
to the channel and i'll see you next
time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]